there's a car race underway pitting
traditional economy because again some
up stuff some Silicon Valley the finish
line getting self-driving cars on the
road first and maps are the fuel in this
race it was really about getting you
from eight of these the maps are
transitioning now from being something
visual to something that's embedded
inside the car it's really gonna become
a component of the car but not only
helps you get from A to B but it's
actually gonna help the car drive it's
also knowing everything in real time
it's an extremely complex business so
why would BMW Daimler and Audi team up
to spend 3.1 billion dollars to acquire
Nokia's map division because the car
makers are afraid of ceding control to
the likes of Apple and Google and what
makes these maps even more valuable
there are that many map data sets in the
world Apple with a nascent product
Google in its Google Maps there's TomTom
out of Amsterdam and Nokia's gear there
was some thought that it might go higher
so the automakers may have landed a
sweet deal letting the map the future of
the auto industry
you